a rabbit
hi oh la
what the hell am I wearing let's take it
easy drugs are still wearing off what
happened
around the fireflies
turns out there's a whole lot more like
you really
people that are immune dozens actually
ain't I'm a damn bit of good news
they vex us what the [ __ ] does happen
furniture
I'm taking this home
sorry wait yeah go please you just come
after her Oh
looks like we were walking back said
said a should be a straight shot through
here
alright
actually kind of pretty ain't it oh [ __ ]
sorry
alright
i watch your head Goldberg
yeah I got it
better than my age now yeah the place is
huge yeah it's over here that's right
don't think I ever told you better
laughs [ __ ]
I bet I would have
[ __ ] a jump off right here
ah Chuck hello jack how's that awesome
look singularity yeah Joel did not get
far when I took that dieter Jesus down
down there
I can't [ __ ] see [ __ ]
it's a little bit further now
ah what the hell is that
yeah i got you a shout of clapping now
come on hey wait how's that that is it
hi ah back in Boston back when I was
bitten I wasn't alone my best friend was
there and she got bit too we didn't know
what to do so she says let's just wait
it out you know we can be all poetic and
just lose our minds together I'm still
waiting for my turn le her name was
Riley and she was the first to die and
then it was tests and then Sam none of
that is on you oh you don't understand I
struggled for a long time with surviving
and you no matter what you keep finding
something to fight for now I know that's
not what you want to hear I swear to me
what
swear to me that everything that you've
said about the fireflies is true I swear
I swear
ok
Oh how's that
so option guys up young joy anger
it's out for her Amish